everyone this is kevin from the chess
website column and today we're gonna be
looking at the bingo game bit which
derives from the Benoni defense if you
haven't watched the video on the bonomi
defense you may want to watch that first
but we'll go ahead and get into it
starts out with pawn to d4 like
responding Knight to f6
pawn c4 pawn c5 white bringing his pawn
down to d5 and then black playing pawn
to b5 this is a very aggressive game
that that black has and what it does
it's one of the most respected gambits
that you will see in chess and basically
white is going to be up an extra pawn
and material but black is going to get
sufficient counter play on the Queen
side and we'll take a look at what that
looks like now why does have the option
of declining the game but one of the
most popular lines that you'll see in
the decline line is Knight to f3 but
this is very uncommon so today we're
gonna look at the various lines that
come from the accepted line and that is
fish to me pawn takes on b5 and from
here blacks gonna have the same move
every time and that's pawn to a6 and
what black is looking to do is he's
looking to give up both his pawns he's
gonna get this one back but he's looking
to give up his pawns on the B and a foul
so he can have semi-open files for his
rooks he's eventually going to want to
castle on the King side he's gonna want
to bring both his rooks to the a file
and the B file so his roots can reign
havoc down on the Queen side in the
chess game you're normally going to
attack the King side or the Queen side
and Black's gonna give up that material
early on so we can have massive attack
on the Queen side later on so here's
where we're gonna spend a lot of our
time there's a few options if White has
in this situation the most common that
you will see this for the pawn to
capture on a6 and from here Black's
going to recapture with his fish
on a six he's developing his bishop no
reason to take with our our rook and not
our Bishop we want to develop a peace
while we're taking and at the same time
we're putting a lot of pressure on the
Kings side of life why we would really
like to develop his LightSquared Bishop
it's his most powerful Bishop and for
white but he can't play a move like III
because then black can come in switch
off bishops but now White's King can no
longer castle so it gives a lot of
problems for white to try to develop his
LightSquared Bishop from here a lot of
times you will see white develop his
Knight to c3 and then black is going to
bring his pawn to d6
and from here as you can tell since we
have a pawn on e7 d6 and c5 blacks
planning on finding ketamine his bishop
meaning he's planning on playing g6 he's
then gonna play Bishop to g7 he's gonna
catch him King side he can bring his
queen to c7 he can bring his Queen to b6
this Knight here is eventually gonna
come to d7 and then we're gonna bring
our rook to b8 and this is gonna put a
lot of pressure on the Queen side of
white
this is the ideal setup that Blackwood
won in the bingo game as you can see
Black has both his roofs on the BNA file
which are both simio pin so he has a lot
of pressure on the Queen side also the
King is very safe here after the black
bishop is being carried on the King side
as you can see black still has a
reasonable amount of pressure in the
middle and even though why this up in
material bought one pawn black has a
huge attack that he can make anytime on
the Queen side so even though black is
down the material at this point a lot of
black players actually prefer this
position just because of all the
attacking lines that they can have in
this particular situation another move
you will see in the Banco gambit is from
here instead of the white pawn taking on
a6 you'll see a move like III and what
this does is a few thing it allows the
LightSquared Bishop for white to attack
this b v square and at the same time it
doesn't block in its development white
now has the option and the example we
looked at before white pretty much is
guaranteed to fincad o as bishop meaning
he's gonna bring his pawn to g3 and then
bring his bishop to g2 but here white
has options he doesn't have to if black
captures on b5
the LightSquared bishop for white can
now come into the five and recapture
whereas before white couldn't do that
because then his keen connect castle
once the bishops were traded off so this
is an idea that you may see a lot of
times from white another very popular
move that you'll see instead of III a
lot of times you'll see white brings
pawn to b6 and you may look at it and
say that's a kind of funny move it
doesn't do too much for white but what
it does do is it doesn't allow black to
gain control that V&A files like you
would yes black does have a semi-open
file on the B file but he doesn't have
the BNA file White's going to give back
the material that he took he's going to
give it back in exchange once the Queen
takes on b6 White's now going to play
excuse me he's first gonna play Knight
to c3 and then he's going to look to
play pawn to e4 after pawn to d6 what's
gonna play pawn to e4 and why it's
basically saying I'm going to give back
the material to black even things up in
exchange I'm going to focus completely
on the center control so a lot of why
players if they don't like getting into
the bingo game but now if you're playing
white and someone offers up the bingo
game but it's not wrong to accept it but
just know that your Queen side is going
to be attacked and it's going to be
harassed the entire game so if you don't
want to deal with that
I highly recommend responding like this
playing with your pond down to v6 and
after the Queen captures on v6 then just
developing your night to see three good
central control and then developing your
pawn to e4 eventually you can bring your
pawn to e5 not right away but once you
build up pieces in center control you
can do that why it's gonna try to apply
a lot of pressure to the center and then
attack on the king side obviously blacks
king is going to be castle on the King
side is gonna think it was Bishop to the
king side and so White's going to try to
counter play and attack on the King side
so these are a few things you may see in
the bingo game if you are a very
aggressive player for black you may want
to try this out especially if you like
attacking the King side excuse me the
Queen side and you're very comfortable
thing getting your bishop on the King
side putting a lot of pressure on the
Queen side this is a very good at sac if
you're white you do have a lot of
options if you want to hold on to the
material and play the mainline or you
can decline or you can give back the
material right away in the example that
would just look that so hope you guys
are a little bit more familiar with the
bingo game try it out sometime let me
know how it worked out thanks for
watching the video if you haven't
already please subscribe then I'll see
you guys next video thanks for watching